hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen episode von kari antwortet
heute mit easy hallo in einem riesenrad
auf sylt
ja wir sind gerade ganz schnell hier
eingestiegen und mir ist gerade
aufgefallen
du hast höhenangst oder ja weil ich
bekämpfe sie immer wenn ich kann jetzt
gerade omas schlimmer jetzt geben wir
darunter ist alles in ordnung aber
gleich geben wieder hoch wie sie muss
ganz langsam rüben wir übersetzen in
diesem format nicht das heißt wir reden
langsam ohne unterschied
ich kann das noch mal ganz langsam
erklären ich habe höhenangst
das heißt sie zwei meter auf einen stein
klettert kriegt sie panik ja das stimmt
ich weiß schon auf der bühne die war
bestimmt zehn meter hoch jetzt sind wir
einmal rumgefahren jetzt können wir
aussteigen und ist die schöne musik
wahnsinn
hinter uns seht ihr das meer wir sind
jetzt am nördlichsten punkt von
deutschland es gibt noch einen kleinen
ein kleine insel die noch da vorne ist
ein kleiner zipfel von einer insel also
sie gehört zu dieser insel
da waren wir eben das ist wirklich der
allernötigste punkt und hier ist
eigentlich schon dänemark auf der
anderen seite und wir wollen heute mal
wieder ein paar kommentare beantworten
aber kurz am anfang wir haben schon
lange kein karree an fortschritte
gemacht und ihr habt uns schon ganz oft
geschrieben dass wir endlich wieder
videos machen sollen und wir möchten uns
erst mal entschuldigen dass wir das
nicht gemacht haben weil ja ich glaube
werden schon seit drei monaten oder ja
noch kein video gemacht und einer der
gründe dafür ist auch dass ich in
letzter zeit krank war oder noch immer
noch bin
und ja viel zeit mit kranksein verbracht
habe
leider und ja viele von euch wissen das
schon vor allem unsere pence wir haben
euch das schon geschrieben und das war
leider ja nicht so eine gute zeit und es
hat auch sehr viel energie für mich
gekostet und deswegen haben wir viele
zusätzliche sachen die wir machen
wollten
in dieser zeit nicht gemacht unter
anderem auch dieses format nicht also
wir haben immer nur das sozusagen unsere
haupt formate gemacht dass nur die
normale easyjet am sonntag und die super
easy german und haben leider nicht so
viel energie gehabt andere sachen zu
machen aber wir bemühen uns das zu
machen und an dieser stelle möchte ich
mich auch bedanken auch im namen von
janosch der hinter der kamera sitzt da
seht ihr seinen daumen denn es ist uns
gerade in den letzten monaten wo es mir
oft schlecht ging und wir auch oft ja
nicht so viel ja nicht so viel energie
haben nicht so viele möglichkeiten
hatten alle unsere träume zu
verwirklichen zum beispiel hatten wir
eine österreich tour geplant die wir
auch euch angekündigt haben die wir
leider absagen mussten
aber wir haben gemerkt dass gerade umso
wichtiger ist uns aufgefallen dass das
unser traumjob ist genau das was wir
hier machen und ihr helft uns auch dabei
diesen traumjob umzusetzen wenn ihr seid
unsere zuschauer dank euch verdienen wir
geld mit dem was wir machen vor allem
dank euch den patch 1 ging sie macht ein
foto und das bedeutet uns unglaublich
viel denn damit dass ihr uns unterstützt
können wir diesen job machen
das ist einfach toll weil wir müssen
nicht uns um andere jobs gehen und
gerade wenn man krank ist und nicht ihr
einen regulären job in einem regulären
job arbeiten können ist das unglaublich
wichtig dass man weiß dass man einfach
mit 500 leuten die einen unterstützen
weil sie das geil finden was man macht
einem helfen das zu machen
vielen dank dafür an euch und jetzt
kommen wir schon
zu den fragen ich hoffe unsere eltern da
unten wollen auch gefilmt werden guck
mal da vorne steht mein vater jetzt
kannst du doch mal drauf gehen
ich glaube wir sind schon durch und darf
das waren sofort
ich glaube wir müssen aussteigen und
noch mehr fragen draußen antworten schon
vorbei kommen wir jetzt zu euren
kommentaren vor kurzem haben wir ein
video gemacht über spitznamen und
kosenamen hast du das eigentlich gesehen
sie sehen ich fand das sehr amüsant und
wir haben euch gebeten uns eure
spitznamen zu schicken und die besten
lese ich jetzt vor
gandhi russell schreibt herz gebackenes
arschlöcher kitsches mail schreibt
kitsch ist sie beschreibt cutie baby
krümel kleinkind kriegskind knödel keks
kenne ist kind knödel finde ich
irgendwie yvonne an der donau
hallo ihr wurden schreibt alte
schabracke auch ganz süß ganz lieb becky
schreibt früher hat meine mama mir mich
schickt wie genannt also kichererbse und
mein vater little berghoff robisch das
heißt kleine kleiner müllbeutel meine
eltern haben das erste schick schick wie
finde ich süß hat dein vater hat es aber
nicht mit ihr gemeint und kleine
kichererbse du setzt die schreibblockade
niemals
mai someone köpfchen äußern times
trocken kurz pak fa
nicht mal im all vor sie hatten ein cup
in mexiko abraham armando karelien
schreibt in mexiko sagt man nie perez
nada es heißt mein schlechter mein
schlechter ist gar nichts nicht nett
aber lustig ok alejandro karte schreibt
hrw everything about the way you know
car is love nicknamen spanish secude
carreño ja-stimmen verringert
haben sich mama und papa doch was war
gedacht kinga da der ist mein bester
frechen jogger auf polnisch auch so
konnte ich andere schützen oder das herz
gehirn und klein-klein ist verschieden
kleines frei stehen ja nicht was sagst
du schon immer mit der kamera wenn du
irgendwas ihr sollte dich jetzt so
nennen heißt das ja oder heißt dass man
einen 38 schreibt wie spitz war welche
spitzname ich habe kascha es kommt von
cachaca bedeutet schnaps im futter diese
stadt ist das nicht superstar kaká bei
uns jetzt alle portugiesisch sprechen
den richtigen schatz ich glaube die
ressource ja aber wissen dann aber das
ist doch schon mal wieso da frag ich
mich gefahren als ich das gelesen habe
wieso haben die deutschen sind doch
meister im schnaps trinken warum haben
wir keine schnaps spitznamen warum in
rheine schnäppchen mein kleines sein
denn wir können kein schnaps mein
lieblings korn mein wort gleichen
dort kann es auch nicht nein sagen wir
da noch zu schnaps kurzem ein kurzer
sagt mandarinen zeit schreibt im
koreanischen denn viele eltern ihre
kinder etwas auf koreanisch nämlich pups
münchen
außerdem schreibt via livestream
wie auch anders jack o lantern schreibt
janisch cracks me up mich auch ist ab
und zwar jeden morgen jeden mittag jeden
abend was der alles macht kannst du
gleich gestellt jetzt zum beispiel
gerade diese kanzlerin videoverleih
machen wie er da sitzt und film
okay dann muss ich das noch nie habe ich
das ist einfach ein
also habe ich das einfach ein geborener
spaß
guck mal hier klingt doch mal was will
ruft schreiben mein erster freund hat
mich immer mein flauschiges mammut
genannt und zu ihm habe ich
rattenschwanz gesagt die fusion elle
schreibt eure witze sind einfach nur
langweilig aber jetzt kommen wir zu
unserem thema jobs überhaupt
und ganz viele leute wir haben das war
am anfang gesagt aber ganz viele leute
haben nicht verstanden dass wir nicht
die besten witze über deutsche
vorgelesen haben sondern die besten
witze die unsere zuschauer also ihr zu
uns geschickt haben und klar da waren
noch ein paar wenige krassere witze bei
aber wir wollten jetzt auch nicht so
mega krasse ehrlich gesagt so richtige
scheiß holocaust witze wollte jetzt auch
nicht vorlesen weil das der hätte noch
also da hätte auch keiner darüber
gelacht und ansonsten waren hass die
besten witze die er uns geschickt habe
und da haben wir so kommentare bekommen
wie zum beispiel eure witze sind einfach
nur langweilig das sollten die besten
witze sein schreibt daniel seibert
diese witze sind so unter ihres schlecht
schreibt jakob vollenweider german jobs
obed max live das ist schon ein
richtiger einstellung das wollten wir es
tut uns leid wenn ihnen nicht darüber
lachen content über unsere witze sie
waren jetzt auch nicht der brüller das
stimmt natürlich hast du die gesehen die
vorhaben witze vorgelesen außer internet
ich bin auch nicht so der witze vorleser
aber wir dachten wir können es ja mal
versuchen
und das habt ihr ein paar alternative
witze noch geschickt ich muss sagen die
sind halt auch so mitteln wer gewann die
tour de france die zwölfte deutsche
panzer division das halt auch kein witz
über deutsche
und an emmi schreibt wenn ich schon höre
deutschen keinen humor so darf man wird
schon wieder kategorisiert das ist so
dumm
ja das haben wir ja nicht gesagt aber es
gibt natürlich international in der welt
gibt es natürlich ein witz dass die
deutschen weniger humor haben und es ist
schon ein bisschen wenn man so um die
welt natürlich haben deutschen humor
aber deutsch noch einmal einen anderen
humor und da muss als solcher auch mal
drüber lachen können das ist ja gerade
dass der humor wenn man da auch sogar
lachen kann
also schickt uns weiterhin eure witze
und wir werden das auf jeden fall
wiederholen oder ja nicht schreiben wir
ja ja ich mag es ja leute das war's auch
schon also ihr könnt uns gerne weiter
wird zu schicken ihr könnt auch witze
darüber machen dass unsere witze scheiße
waren
ihr könnt auch witze darüber machen dass
die deutschen keinen humor haben ehrlich
gesagt ist das auch egal
es ist jetzt nicht so wichtig weil wir
fühlen uns dadurch nicht angegriffen
easy wie fandest du denn die riesenrad
fashion ganze gesicht ich bin sehr
enttäuscht von der kürzer viel zu kurz
ich glaube 5 haben gesagt dass wir im
zweier ohne jahres meint dass man in
vier jahren also nicht mitgezählt drei
runden ist so super kurz es werden jetzt
zwei wir gewesen sie hätten länger
gehalten das stimmt ja das war ihr könnt
uns wieder fragen schicken ich kann
nicht versprechen dass ich nächste woche
ein neues video mache ich kann nicht
versprechen dass ich das in zwei wochen
mache aber sobald wir zeit und lust
haben und muße ganz wichtig machen wir
ein neues video
also schickt uns eure fragen hier in die
kommentare
ja genau und ja ihr seid einfach dabei
unterstützt die german darüber freuen
wir uns sehr
das ermöglicht uns das ganze als job zu
machen das könnte hier machen und
abonniert unseren kanal natürlich bis
bald
ciao